this video is sponsored by Squarespace
we'll be talking more about them at the
end of this video so I've been making
these countdowns of my top 10 and my
second top 10 favorite exercises lately
and people seem to enjoy that but then
one commenter said that they found it a
little bit confusing it was too much how
would you program all of this it would
take too long and that's before I've
even added the next 10 I want to make a
list of 30 in total so at first I got a
bit bristly about this I'm like what do
you want you got 10 exercises here most
workouts are going to involve 10
exercises and as somebody who thinks
it's really important to train every
aspect of your performance rotation
Mobility all that good stuff you know by
now I find it really hard to narrow down
exercises it's like sure you could do
just three exercises but you'd be
leaving loads on the table you'd be
lacking in all sorts of areas so you
know what do you want from me but then I
thought about it and I thought Adam this
guy is issuing you a challenge think of
it as a thought experiment if you only
could give someone three exercises to
get the maximum amount of performance
from just those three what would those
three moves be and I know that a lot of
people would find this useful because a
lot of us do want something simple that
we can just take away and apply really
easily we want something quick that's
going to give us the most bang for our
buck many people The Big Three means
squat deadlift and bench press and
whilst they're useful they're all in the
sagittal plane they all train max
strength they don't involve much
Mobility so I wondered what is my big
three what's my big three for all-around
performance now this is a different list
than my top 10 exercise it's different
from what I would do personally it's
different from what I would program for
anybody because I've chosen these
exercises with the understanding that
you're not doing anything else at all so
you're not going to get a lot of intense
work on a single area but you should get
a very broad full body workout and I'm
pretty proud of what I came up with I
think this list of three whilst it's
always better to do more if you want
something that's going to carry you over
with the basic amount of full body
performance total performance then I
think these three are as close as I'm
gonna get and it has been interesting
and fun coming up with them and I'd love
to hear yours in the description down
below and we need to come up with like a
catchy marketable name I was thinking
some alliteration like the
functional three so what are the
functional three exercises well we're
going to start with the lizard crawl now
I like crawls a lot as you guys know but
I'm talking specifically the lizard
crawl here and performed in the way that
I like to perform it now this is giving
you all kinds of stuff we won't go down
nice and low on that one side and then
Bob up as we're going that's making this
essentially a one-armed push-up with
each step this is great of course for
training your pecs triceps your
shoulders and in quite a decent way as
well having a wrist in that position is
great for strengthening them and
building wrist Mobility your core not
only needs to stay rigid as your body
needs to stay parallel to the ground it
also needs to not twist to one side when
you're putting your weight on just one
hand but it also needs to intentionally
twist when you're bringing your leg up
to the side so you have anti-rotation
and rotation here as well you'll be
pushing off your feet As you move
forwards which makes it a little bit
useful for your calves you're going to
be on your tippy toes and as you bring
your leg up to the side this is great
for treading a little bit of hip
mobility not turns but certainly better
than nothing and I made a whole video
talking about how important hip mobility
is because it allows us to get deep into
a squat it allows us to drop into a
Cossack Squad before my roundhouse kick
poor hit Mobility leads to batch issues
knee issues so yeah this is huge so
getting all of that from one exercise
so this is your starting position notice
you've got your right arm forward left
leg forwards or vice versa this is what
we mean by contralateral and what you're
going to do is reach forward with your
left hand and your right leg as you do
that you're going to be pushing yourself
up on that side making it as I say
almost like a one-handed push-up this is
where you're going to get that Peck
training tricep training and shoulder
training at the same time you want to
make sure you're bringing your hip up
nice and far next to you as you go like
this and you should feel a slight
stretch there
getting that little bit of hip mobility
in there as well you're gonna be keeping
your torso strong so that you're not
sagging at the waist so you're getting
that bit there and then at the same time
as you bring up you're naturally going
to be twisting your body slightly
getting that little bit of rotation as
well get extra credit if you go up and
downhill which will place more emphasis
on the shoulders as you're going
downhill and more emphasis on the legs
as you're going uphill also get a little
bit of glute and stuff in there as well
this way and because you're crawling in
lots of different directions and stuff
it's also highly Dynamic and that's what
we want to go for here we want movements
where possible that aren't just linear
repetitions where every rep is slightly
different repetition without repetition
as you would say because this builds
more resilient motor patterns more
resilient strength because in the real
world things aren't in straight lines
and if you want to prepare yourself for
as many situations as possible
especially if you've only got three
exercises that's how you want to do it
and it's moving in all three planes
simultaneously as you bring your legs up
to the side you're moving in the frontal
plane as you rotate the core you're
moving in the transverse plane because
you're calling forwards you're also
moving in the sagittal plane how many
exercises can say that it's also fun and
engaging it's great for brain
development and Agility and coordination
because it's a contralateral movement
because you're moving your hands and
legs in opposition it's just fantastic
analysical can be performed to give you
strength endurance as in you can go a
long distance or if you really feel it
as you go down onto one side it can be
used to develop a little bit more
strength so yeah it's very versatile in
that sense too so that's why I highly
recommend the lizard crawl as the first
of the functional three each time I say
that it's annoying me next we need to do
something for the legs and I was
struggling a little bit here because on
the one hand I wanted like a squat
something that's just going to build big
strong legs and also give you that
Mobility dipping down but on the other
hand I thought we really need a hip
hinge in here of some sort because
that's so important for picking things
up off the ground for preventing injury
Etc and because we need to fit a lot
into a small number of exercises it'd
also be great if we can get some bonus
stuff in there too
at first I had a hybrid exercise in mind
I was thinking we could do some kind of
kettlebell swing into a squatting
overhead press and that would be pretty
good but ultimately I decided on the
crossbody clean and press so usually we
use a kettlebell you're going to put
that down on the floor in front of one
leg then you're going to squat and hinge
down reach across with the opposite arm
bring it up into the rack position and
then press it overhead note that this
isn't a clean and jerk this is a clean
and press because I want that vertical
pushing Motion in there with it I want
to build actual strength in the
shoulders this way this was one of the
reasons I chose this exercise at the
same time you might notice we again have
rotation as we're rotating to pick up
that weight and you might notice that we
have both a bit of a squat and a hinge
so we're gonna hinge as far as we can go
and then squat down the rest of the way
to pick it up ideally I'd like this to
be a bit more squat in there but you do
feel it in the legs as well as the
shoulders and you're also getting a
little bit of a curl in there a little
bit of a pull in there it's really
really good I like to do this in a kind
of quick motion so what I will tend to
do is to squat down pick up the weight
and then instead of holding it in that
rack position for a second I just kind
of do it all in one motion so some
people say like is he trying to do a
snatch or what but no it's a clean and
press but I just do it quickly because I
don't want to just be standing there
like this like a lemon also I just find
it more fun I've got the momentum of the
upwards movement and I just transfer
that into a press but it's still like I
say very much a press we're training the
shoulders we're not training the lower
body to develop that explosiveness
this is great of course because you're
getting that practice for your hip hinge
in quite a safe way you've also got a
rotation and often when we pick things
up off the ground we are rotating and
there's a bit of a squat and if we
combine a little bit of leg stuff that
we're getting from the crawls with a
little bit of leg stuff we're getting
from our crossbody clean and press that
I think this is you know close enough
considering what we've got to work with
here so to perform this movement what
you're going to do is you're going to
place the weight down on the floor in
front of the opposite leg you're going
to hinge and squat down and grab the
opposite hand and bring it up into the
racked position when it's in this
position it should be resting on the
soft part of your arm you want it quite
close into the body not out like this
and then you're just going to push it
overhead as you do that you want to make
sure you're keeping your fist straight
so imagine you trying to punch the
ceiling you don't want that bent broken
wrist position it's not the end of the
world right away most people can get
away with it with a lighter weight but
if you do it a lot if you're fatigued or
if you're using a heavier weight that's
an invitation to injure yourself and
like I say we're not doing a explosive
jerk movement we're just
pushing because we want to build that
strength and as you hinge down of course
you want to make sure that you are
hinging that means that you're not
bending your lower spine I've made
videos talking about how to do this and
we're going to have a little bit of a
squat as well making it similar to a
squatting kettlebell swing which is
actually a variation of the kettlebell
swing that develops more ground reaction
forces these exercises you'll notice
that they are targeting specific muscle
groups but they're also kind of full
body exercises so it's somewhere between
the two and the final option on my list
is the bodyweight row you're going to
find a bar or two bars around waist
height so a bit higher off the ground
you're gonna grab them with your hands
and you're going to row your upper body
up towards them whilst keeping your legs
nice and so as you're putting yourself
up what you want to make sure you're
doing
is retracting your scapula
pinching them behind yourself this is
useful for developing strength for a
range of more advanced movements it's
also really good for your posture and
for your shoulder stability at the same
time you're also getting a little bit of
rear delt work in there this is
important to improve our posture because
so many of us are always hunched
forwards especially if we're doing a lot
of front heavy exercises as well I chose
this more horizontal pulling motion
instead of a vertical one like a pull up
or chin up for this reason but at the
same time you will find that it does
transfer to a vertical pull it will
improve your climbing ability if you're
using your arms and at the same time
you're getting a little bit of work for
your torso again because you're keeping
your feet flat on the floor and then
you're trying to keep your torso rigid
this makes it anti-flexion you're trying
to prevent your butt from folding in and
touching the ground to strengthening
your posterior muscles to keep your body
nice and straight this is a really nice
added bonus to the move this was the one
I was the most uncertain about and there
is a higher level option which has some
different benefits so if you find that
too easy then what I want you to do is
an arched back pull up grab a bar that's
above you this time but you're going to
arch your back so that you're still
preventing your sternum up towards the
bar and in both versions you want to
touch the sternum onto the bar then
you're going to pull yourself up like
that this is still more of a horizontal
row it's a lot more difficult of course
so you're pulling your whole body weight
still getting the rear delt still
getting the rhomboids as you retract the
scapula at the same time you've got a
little bit of back extension this is
really good for your general mobility
and spine health so that's a perk I
really like it for that reason and for
even more added benefit I want to do it
from a tree branch because when you
perform a pull-up from a tree branch
again every movement is slightly
different hanging from a tree branch
rather than a bar gives you extra credit
because every single time you perform a
pull up or chin up from a tree branch
your hands are at slightly different
levels you're going to have different
thicknesses of Branch so you're training
a grip more the angle is going to be
slightly different all these things mean
that you're not just training the same
linear motion over and over again you're
reinforcing those neural Pathways but
you're building more robust neural
patterns meaning that when you are out
in the real world and a movement doesn't
exactly mimic what you perform in the
gym your body is better prepared for
that better prepared in terms of having
practiced it in terms of the fascia
surrounding the muscle and in terms of
the stabilizing muscles so the
functional three is the lizard crawl
it's the crossbody clean and press and
it's the bodyweight row or if you're
strong enough the Arch Back pull up from
a tree so there you go if you're
underneath the exercises and you want
your body to be as performant as
possible then these are the three that I
highly recommend but like I say there's
always going to be compromises there's
stuff missing here and the intensity is
relatively low still I'm pretty happy
that in terms of targeting everything
all at once you've got max strength
you've got strength endurance you've got
Mobility you've got movement in the
frontal and rotational planes you've got
wrist strengthening you've got a bit of
spine extension you've got stabilizing
and strengthening the Torso improving
hip mobility building coordination all
sorts of stuff that so often goes
overlooked I'm pretty happy with it and
guys if you're interested in using these
three exercises as your full workout
then head over to thebioneer.com I'll
put a link in the description down below
and there you'll find a completely free
mini routine mini workout and a little
bit of explanation about progressions
and things and you can start doing that
right away completely free you can just
go and read the blog post and if you do
try this of course let me know how you
get on with it but I'd love to know what
your three exercises would be if you
could only train with three or how about
if you could only train with five are
any of you out there going to try using
this as your workout I'd recommend doing
it three or four times a week if you do
and the whole thing should only take
about 15 minutes if you want a more
in-depth program that includes these
exercises but also a whole ton more for
far more comprehensive total body
performance trains not only things like
max strength and Mobility but also
coordination balance endurance even
brain function then check out super
functional training 2.0 in the
description down below it comes with an
80 plus page ebook over two hours of
instructional training video and a
routine that you can perform pretty much
from anywhere with very minimal
equipment so yeah check that out but
either way thank you so much for
watching guys I'll see you next time
bye for now
now let's talk a bit about today's
sponsor Squarespace so Squarespace is a
website building platform that makes it
extremely easy for anybody to get their
own website up and running that means no
code no experience with web design
literally anyone can do this and I'm
talking within 10 minutes or less you
start off by choosing a template you
like the looks of then you use the
intuitive fluid engine to Simply drag
and drop the elements you like where you
want them that way you can take
something that already looks great and
then customize it to your exact
specification not only is Squarespace
extremely easy to get started with
though it also comes loaded with all of
the features you could possibly need to
take your website and your business as
far as it could possibly go in fact many
of the biggest brands on the web use
Squarespace for example as advanced
publishing features you can schedule
your posts use Advanced formatting it
has a fully integrated commenting system
for managing your community with
threaded comments replies and likes
seamless social media integration if you
want to include your social posts
directly on your website there's
e-commerce tools there's gated members
only content for Revenue generation
where you can think of and you can add
even more features thanks to third-party
plugins allowing you to do all sorts of
additional stuff for example on the
e-commerce side you can add things like
global Shipping and inventory management
if you want to learn more head over to
squarespace.com and when you're ready to
launch go to squarespace.com forward
slash bioneer for 10 off your first
domain or website thanks again to
Squarespace for sponsoring this video
and thanks to you guys for sticking
around till the end bye for now